we turn to Fox News senior judicial
analyst Judge Andrew Napolitano and
judge maybe we put you in the category
of those who don't totally believe the
story on a pen register I don't believe
the story on the on the pen register on
a day in which the president's chief
lawyer just threw a bombshell unto many
of the president's defenses do you
really think the Justice Department is
going to admit that they listen to phone
calls from the president they may not
have recorded but I assure they were
listening if they were listening they
can't use anything they hear as a basis
for an affidavit of probable cause or in
a prosecution but it can send them
seeking other means to obtain evidence
to support that yeah basically called
parallel reconstruction you find
something you weren't supposed to have
access to so you find a different way to
get a that's different and lawful way to
get access to it so that you can present
it to a court what when the michael
cohen asked that the documents seized by
the FBI be returned the government said
we there's there's no privilege here
because of the crime fraud exception
that means they had enough information
from those phone calls to suggest that
michael cohen
or his client were participating in a
crime or a fraud and we're masking the
phone calls as attorney-client privilege
and they weren't okay let's talk through
now the potential legal ramifications of
what rudy giuliani
revealed last night he says he's
discussed it with the president here's
what the president tweeted out today
we'll walk through this mr. Cohen that's
his attorney an attorney received a
monthly retainer not from the campaign
and having nothing to do with the
campaign from which he entered into
through reimbursement a private contract
between two parties known as the
non-disclosure NDA these agreements are
very common among celebrities and people
of wealth in this case it is in full
force and effect and will be used in
arbitration for damages against miss
Clifford Daniels the agreement was used
to stop the false and extortionists
accusations made by her about an affair
despite already having signed a detailed
letter admitting there was no affair
prior to its violation by Miss Clifford
and her attorney this was a private
agreement money from the campaign or
campaign contributions played no role in
this transaction so now we get to the
question of how this money was allegedly
repaid to Michael Cohen is there
potential for a fraud charge in there
there is a potential for a
charge here because one of the reasons
that the president Trump was able to say
he knew nothing about the agreement is
his name doesn't appear in there and he
didn't sign it Michael Cullen and and
miss Daniels then lawyer not her current
lawyer used a pseudonym
David Dennison in place of Donald Trump
so the question is is that even a valid
agreement since the person who
purportedly binds the president didn't
actually sign it the president is
correct when he says that non-disclosure
agreements are common with respect to
celebrities a lot of celebrities compel
everybody that works for them to sign
non-disclosure agreements because they
may see something that they don't want
disclosed but it would be a violation of
legal ethics if Michael Cohen paid a
settlement in a case out of the retainer
which was intended for his own fees and
his own expenses it's also to me
inconceivable that Donald Trump who was
notoriously aware of where every dollar
he has is going was not aware that
130,000 was going to stormy Daniels
well conceivable as he has said here it
appears in what Rudy Giuliani said to
place listen wealthy busy people don't
always know what's being fixed or taken
care of on their behalf they've
authorized someone to do it they just do
it they don't have to get involved with
the detail may very well be the case and
and there may have been a method to Rudy
Giuliani's mentioning this last night
knowing Rudy's mind as I think I do have
none of her 25 years he likes to focus
on discrete legal issues so we wanted to
take the stormy Daniels Michael Cohen
issue off the table I don't know if he
succeeded by what he said last night
because I don't know that the White
House and the President and certainly
mr. Cohen were prepared for this
remember he's not Michael Cohen's lawyer
Cohen today seemed stunned by what he
heard last night but this is off the
plate it appears in the Muller
investigation or the Southern District
investigation with respect to the
president quickly stormy Daniels
attorney currently Michael avenatti who
doesn't miss the chance to weigh in on
the case said he believes that Cohen
will be indicted on several serious
criminal charges and he's continuing to
predict he says the president doesn't
make it through his first term because
of legal issues well I don't know about
the press
not making through his the first term it
depends on what Bob Muller comes up with
I happen to think that the Muller
investigation is a very serious one and
they have accumulated a lot of evidence
that Rudy Giuliani and the president
don't want to confront and I don't know
where Michael Cohen gets this at Michael
avenatti gets this term except that the
Los Angeles federal district court judge
before whom the strong McDaniels versus
Donald Trump case is assigned stayed the
case for 90 days quote until Michael
Cohen is indicted I don't know if he
knows something that the rest of us
don't know where this is just a neutral
judicial mind looking at the facts
saying there's going to be an indictment
here with that discussion of Cohen
taking the fifth as well all right judge
always great to see you always a
pleasure very much